[Music]
so here we are in february and we
already have seen quite a number of
giant monsters and movies and shows and
quite a few more in trailers the year
2022 will not be a boring scene even
though there is no legendary godzilla
this year there will be other versions
of the kaiju as well as other gigantic
bees that will rock the screens
we will see them all over the place in
netflix disney the cinema halls and more
so here in this video we will showcase
20 movies and shows which will have them
you know a lot of kaiju and a lot of
giant monsters and all of them will be
seen in 2022 so let's get to it
number one rancor in the book of boba
fett if you haven't seen the book of
birth fat which is a spin-off of the
mandalorian then you should definitely
watch it you should go to disneyplus and
watch it and to those who don't have an
account there then you know there are
other sites wing-wing
the rancor is one of the most famous
creatures of the star wars universe and
was seen first in the jedi returns in
the late 80s and now you will see it
again and it will fight a battle droid
as well as munch on some aliens
number 2 dragons of the house of the
dragon this upcoming prequel series to
game of thrones will showcase more than
just drama of westeros and politics but
will obviously have a lot of dragons and
will feature the biggest of them all
which is valerian the black dread there
will also be other dragons as well from
valyria and two younger siblings to the
black dragon
number three gong in the netflix
monsterverse series where netflix has
filmed and is ready to release an
animated series that will revolve around
a group of shipwrecked characters
inspired by kong skull island of 2017
the anime series will be seen in
legendary's monster verse which will
feature kong the titan ape
you know of that universe as well as
many creatures of skull island and also
other titans this is monster versus
entry for this year
number four shuma gorath or gargantus in
the multiverse of madness
well the trailer to dr strange movie
this year showcased a couple of monsters
as well as even dinosaurs but yeah the
one that was very interesting is the
tentacle creature that might either be
the giant octopus monster called
gargantus or an even deadlier
interdimensional being called
shimagarath the ruler of a hundred
universes
number five a dead kaiju in what to do
with a dead kaiju literally titled giant
monster cleanup in japan the movie is
unique to the genre as it focuses on the
aftermath of a kaiju death after the
monster's demise the body begins to rot
and bloat if its internal gases erupt
from the body the nation of japan could
be destroyed this kaiju looks kind of
like a zilla slash gorosaurus anguirus
remix
number six creatures of pandora in
avatar too yes we also have the
long-awaited sequel to the highest
earning movie of all time and that is
avatar in this upcoming movie set to be
released in december we will again see
the creatures of the planet pandora
which will include the giant leonopteryx
the other flying creatures the
six-legged horses and more and maybe
even new gigantic beasts as well
number seven dinosaurs of jurassic world
dominion well one of the most awaited
movie is the sixth in the jurassic
franchise and this movie will showcase
not just the old dinosaurs that have
been seen in previous flicks but also
new ones like the terry xenosaurus the
flying quezon cordless the new atrocious
raptors the feathered pyro raptor and
the biggest predatory land diner of that
universe the giganotosaurus
number eight orochi in the brush of the
god directed by keizo murasi the
legendary suit maker of countless kaiju
dating back to the 1950s brush of the
god is a movie about a young girl that
in her quest meets a gigantic
eight-headed dragon very similar to
ghidorah but with five more heads
though there is no sudden release date
as yet however it is very likely to be
released by the end of the year
number nine the demiurge or maybe
sidorak in the multiverse of madness
sorry for putting this on another entry
number but in the trailer of doctor
strange we see yet another gigantic
monster that is demonic and magical at
the same time
this is theorized to be either the
demiurge the godly spirit of planet
earth or sidorak which is an immensely
powerful entity that is described as
both a demon and a god
number 10 shin ultraman ultraman is an
alien from a planet called the land of
light in nebula
m78 who chased the monster bermuller to
planet earth he is the first ultra to
visit earth and defended the planet
against the kaiju
this is another japanese movie and yes
if ultraman is there then there will
also be other giant kaijus to fight
against so get ready for a robot vs
kaiju fight in the shin's iteration
number 11 titans of attack on titan the
second part of season 4 of attack on
taran has been aired and more episodes
will follow until march attack on titan
is set in a world where humanity lives
inside cities surrounded by enormous
walls that protect them from titans
gigantic humanoid creatures who devour
humans seemingly without reason
number 12 garathan of aquaman 2. this
december we will have the sequel to the
successful aquaman movie of the dc eu
aquaman and the lost kingdom is
scheduled to be released on december 16
2022 this will follow arthur curry the
aquaman and his new role as the king of
atlantis and alongside him we will
probably see a lot of underwater
creatures and the return of the gigantic
2 mile long karaten
13. godzilla in godzilla's singular
point season 2.
yeah we now come to the g-man although
not stated as to when the second season
of singular point will be released but
it will probably be later this year and
at the most the first part of 2023
godzilla will make a return and will
probably face off against his
doppelganger mecha godzilla in the next
season so get ready for the king of the
monsters
number 14 middle-earth monsters in the
rings of power this series is a prequel
to the highly successful of the rings
and the hobbit but will be set thousands
of years before the events of peter
jackson's films in a trailer we have
already seen a strange troll and as we
know now there will be other dragons and
other terrifying creatures of middle
earth and the heroes of the story will
have to face off against
15 kaijus of pacific rim the black the
giant monsters from the antiverse will
make a comeback for a second season of
the black we will see a continuation of
the last part where the boy kaiju and
jaeger defeated the powerful copperhead
kaiju what next we hope to see more of
slaaden and the other kaijus making a
return to the franchise and fighting
against other jaegers
16. the demogorgon and mind flayer in
stranger things 4 11 and her friends
will be yet in another horrific ordeal
of keeping the earth safe from
interdimensional monsters like the
demogorgon and the mind flayer in the
upcoming fourth season of stranger
things while the release date hasn't
been confirmed we expect the series to
be out in the summer months of this year
17 predator in prey this is the fifth
installment of the predator franchise
this movie is called prey it will be a
prequel to the other films in the
franchise and will showcase a predator
and his first journey to earth the film
will be released in hulu in 2022 we hope
that the makers will stick to the
storyline the original storyline and
that it is unlike the previous failures
of the predator series of movies
the predator for your information is a
highly skilled alien hunter from the
yautya prime planet
18. the crooked man from raising dion
well the second season of the superhero
kit series called raising dion has
already been released in netflix and
here we see super powered individuals
training their abilities and what
monster you ask will be seen well there
is an evil entity able to possess and
even manipulate powered and non-powered
people
and it is called a crooked man it has
electricity and storm-like qualities in
him and he can also grow two enormous
heights maybe around 50-100 feet tall
nineteen aliens of the covenant in halo
now from the gaming industry we will
finally have the long-awaited series of
halo where we will follow the master
chief john 117 in its mission to save
the human race from the alien invaders
called the covenant these aliens are
mostly human size but
some are also a bit bigger but some
like the hunters and the brutes are big
in size
with advanced technology they will be
very terrifying to fight against
and lastly 20 project gemini
this is a 2022 russian science fiction
trailer film about a space mission sent
to terraform a distant planet however
things go wrong and the mission
encounters something
unknown that has its own plan for the
planet earth we know not what this
entity is but by the looks of the
posters and the trailer the russians are
about to unleash a cosmic horror monster
to the big screens with tentacles and
whatnot
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video and with that we come to the end
of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam